الترحيب بك في ميامي ميامي فريد جدًا
لأن القليل من
كل شيء تراه في المدينة يكون
لديك شاطئ مشمس دائمًا ولديك منطقة فنية
في وسط المدينة ولديك أيضًا
ليتل هافانا ، التغيير العنيف
يشبه المكان الأيقوني للموسيقى الحية
الطعام والشراب والثقافة الكوبية هنا
في قلب ليتل هافانا ، طعامنا
هو المطبخ الكوبي الأصيل ، وهو أحد
مقبلاتنا المفضلة ، إنه ساندويتش كوبانو
داخل لفة السبرينغ رول ، لذا يوجد في الداخل
شريحة من لحم الخنزير والجبن السويسري
والخردل أيولي مع قطعة صغيرة  مخلل من الداخل ،
إنه جيد حقًا ،
هناك رقص السالسا كل هذا الصباح ،
لذلك على الرغم من أن الأشخاص الذين لا يعرفون
كيفية الرقص يأتون إلى هنا
ويخرجون وهم يعرفون كيفية رقص السالسا ، لذلك
لا توجد أبدًا لحظة مملة هنا مرحبًا
بكم في كل شخص ميامي في المنزل
أحد أكثر النظم البيئية تميزًا في العالم ،
قوارب كوبرتاون الهوائية ، نحن في
وسط قلب إيفرجليدز ، وسنرى
كيف كانت ميامي تبدو قبل أن تكون
جميع المباني  هنا سنرى
بعض الطيور المختلفة ، التمساح ، لدينا
بعض الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض ، يتفاجأ كل من الناس
عندما يأتون إلى هنا
ويدركون أنها قريبة جدًا من
المدينة ، فهي تتراجع بالزمن إلى الوراء
[موسيقى]